bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france l'ancien
conseiller à la sécurité nationale de
donald trump john bolton qui va jeter
certainement un pavé dans la mare avec
son livre doit-on s'attendre à un
événement important aux états unis
risquent d'avoir de vraies révélations
il y aura beaucoup de régulation
stration trompe a essayé d'empêcher la
publication de ce livre
mais les révélations et que se livrent
le renforce
des problèmes qui durent depuis
plusieurs années est-ce que l'initiation
trump ou trump lui même ont ils à
chercher de l'aide auprès de puissances
étrangères pour assurer son élection sa
réélection l'idée est qu'il aurait
essayé de pousser l'ukraine à s'ingérer
dans les élections
cela a occupé les médias américains
pendant presque un an même si tu n'as
trump a finalement été acquitté et voilà
maintenant que effectivement son ancien
conseiller à la sécurité nationale
réveil qu'il aurait pu essayer de faire
la même chose avec le président chinois
je pense effectivement que cela va jeter
de l'huile sur le feu et ceux qui ne
l'ont pas cru la première fois pourrait
le croire maintenant ce qu'ils ont cru
la dernière fois le croiront
certainement cette fois-ci même soin de
quel pourrait être son retentissement de
toutes ces révélations à quatre mois de
la présidentielle américaine
je pense que cela va renforcer les deux
parties les personnes qui soutiennent le
président ne changeront pas d'avis je ne
pense pas qu'ils diront qu'il s'agit
d'une autre tentative de le calomnier le
dire qu'il ne se conduit pas bien en
tant que président ceux qui sont contre
le président diront que cela prouve une
fois de plus que le président a mal agi
les personnes qui étaient convaincus
qu'ils ont essayé qu'il a essayé
d'utiliser l'ukraine
tirons qu'il a essayé également avec la
chine mais la question c'est que
décideront les auteurs indépendants les
électeurs indépendants
je pense que pour beaucoup cela va
représenter des preuves supplémentaires
de corruption ou du fait que le
président ne se place avant les intérêts
du pays on a bien compris que
certainement que les deux camps
resteront voilà campé sur leur position
il n'empêche donald trump sort de cette
crise du coronavirus puis de ces voix-là
de ces émeutes 1 contre les violences
policières il ya maintenant ces
révélations ne donne le bolton ça qui
s'accumulent est ce que ça ne va pas
finir par jouer et peser très fort sur
sa campagne
finalement c'est en fait une avalanche
c'est une boule de neige qui descend la
pente et qui grossit grossit et c'est en
fait toute la montagne qui est en train
de dégringoler sur donald trump
il ya beaucoup de problèmes avec donald
trump
il fait face à une batterie de mauvaises
nouvelles
je vous ai dit la dernière fois que
j'étais ici que donald trump avait un
taux de popularité bien plus bas que
n'importe quel autre président a en
cette période de son mandat il n'est
même pas à 40 % de taux de popularité et
les révolutions et les scandales
s'accumulent donc effectivement cela ne
va pas l'aider
la question c'est est ce que les
électeurs pensent qu'ils ont une
meilleure solution avec eux à joe biden
ou considère-t-il que joe biden lui-même
et corrompu joe biden l'ancien vice
président a également été en connivence
avec l'ukraine et la chine toc c'est la
même personnalité et c'est toujours le
même débat il s'agit de corruption et de
savoir qui est le plus complet autre
dossier
épineux autre révélation la question des
ouigours un donald trump aurait a
promulgué une loi pour sanctionner des
responsables chinois accusés de
l'internement de masse des musulmans
ouïghours de la province du xinjiang
dénonçant aussi une attaque vicieuse la
chine menace que les etats-unis 2-2
contre mesures on imagine que ça va pas
vraiment arrangé la relation déjà tendue
entre ces deux pays en effet l'une des
révolutions dont des révélations les
plus choquant c'est cette discussion qui
aurait eu lieu en juillet 2019
lorsque le président a été informé de
ces plans de ces plans d'avoir des camps
d'internement pour les ouigours le
président aurait dit qu'il pensait que
c'était une bonne idée et qu'il était
d'accord avec cette politique à l'époque
donc dire avec le président jean ping
ping qu' il était d'accord avec lui
c'est vraiment une grosse surprise
l'idée qui laisserait aux côtés qu'il
soutiendrait des comportements que
beaucoup considèrent comme inhumains ou
abusif et ensuite dire publiquement
qu'il va condamner ce comportement tout
en ayant dit auparavant qu'il était
d'accord avec qui il avait donné sa
bénédiction avec ce genre de choses
c'est vraiment très dérangeant alors
c'est vrai que les relations se sont
détériorées entre temps avec la chine
on se souvient des accusations du fameux
entre guillemets virus chinois où on en
est sur ce plan à ce que donald trump a
oublié un petit peu voilà de vouloir
enquêter sur l'origine du virus
ils en parlent encore justement n'ont
plus vraiment le président est passé à
autre chose
il réussit très bien à donner des
sobriquets aux choses c'est ce qui a
fait son succès dans sa carrière
politique il donne des sobriquets à ses
opposants politiques aux sources
médiatiques qui est même au virus avoir
qualifié ce virus de vireux chinois
c'était sa façon de dire ce n'est pas ma
faute ce n'est pas moi qui suis
responsable c'est la faute de la chine
et le président veut passer à autre
chose il ne veut pas prouvée ces
théories il veut simplement taxez ce
virus comme étant chinois pour que les
électeurs le pense aussi
donc il ya effectivement beaucoup de
tensions entre la chine les etats unis
sur beaucoup de sujets mais sur ce sujet
là je pense que le président continuera
à parler d'un virus chinois mais il n'a
aucune intention de prouver ses dires
merci ben soit une journée les
investigations nous avoir fait un
panorama complet sur cette actualité
riche autour de donald trump et on
attend évidemment avec impatience les
révélations du livre de john bolton
merci à vous